just want to remind everybody the Pacman
Finance channel is Live I just want to
show you the type of content that we do
on it it's all personal finance content
there's not really any political stuff
it's just handling basic personal
finance topics many of them are
suggested by you by people in the
audience here is one such segment we did
recently on assets by risk if this stuff
is interesting to you or maybe even if
it's not and you just want to support
the new channel you can go to
youtube.com Pacman Finance that's the
place where all of the content lives
here's the type of thing we do there at
this point I've said so many times risk
and risk tolerance is maybe the
fundamental component of investing
because risk tolerance indicates what
asset allocation you should have now in
general higher risk means the higher
potential return but also the potential
to lose money in general at least if
we've assessed the risk correctly if
you're young you have the room in time
to make riskier investments before
retirement because retirement is further
away unless you want to retire early we
have a clip on that as well if you're
soon retiring or already retired your
tolerance for risk may be much smaller
also the money you have to work with may
be something you need to access in the
short term for example to buy a house
that's also a consideration when it
comes to liquidity and the risk of
investment so we're going to have a
conversation about different asset
classes and types of Investments and
kind of rank them based on risk and if
you're buying one you should know what
is the level of risk that you're taking
on now a couple of things to mention
we're going to be talking about
cash stock index funds individual stocks
bond funds bonds real estate crypto
metals and gambling there are other
asset classes and the other thing is
we're going to talk about the absolute
risk and you're going to see what I mean
in a moment so let's talk let's start
with the least risky lowest risk lowest
reward uh we are talking of course I'm
sure you all know hold on let me get
this up on the screen here we go
um we're talking about cash okay
cash is at the bottom it's the lowest
risk and it's the lowest reward because
of something called FDIC insurance now I
know many of you are going to say David
cash has a huge risk inflation risk if
you have cash earning zero or one
percent and inflation is eight percent
you're losing seven percent that's
terribly risky we're talking about the
absolute volatility and risk and of
course inflation can affect all of these
we have to do that in order to be able
to kind of compartmentalize this
conversation cash in a high you always
want to do a high old savings account
is my opinion right now there are high
yield savings accounts paying I know of
3.25 percent
uh that is actually really good because
we have a higher interest rate
environment you can get more money for
your cash that is an advantage cash can
also go in CDs sometimes it's a money
market account you know that nominally
the money isn't going to shrink you have
FDI FDIC Insurance up to 250 000 per
account so opportunity cost aside
inflation cost aside There is almost no
risk here the downside is there's the
chance of making more than just a couple
percent when the money is deployed in
other assets and over long periods of
time and then you potentially can
mitigate the inflationary risk as well
Beyond this there are it's probably
individual bonds
but you have to be specific about which
bonds okay uh when you go up
a top rated individual Bond something
like for example you know the US has
never defaulted on its Bond debts as an
example so we might say USA there are
other countries that have never
defaulted on bond debts that's probably
the next possibility in terms of going
up in terms of risk
after individual bonds it's probably a
bond fund and the reason I say probably
is specific environments can change the
risk level over small short to medium
term periods of time but we're talking
about generally the reason why a bond
fund is usually riskier than an
individual bond is because instead of
knowing what return you will get with an
individual Bond you know the return
you're subject to bond market
risk and the bond fund value could
decline if interest rates go up since
newly issued bonds will be better deals
so even though bond funds are relatively
lower risk compared to some of the other
Investments we'll talk about it's
important that there's still a risk in
2022
us-based bond funds are down something
like 15 historically unusual and it's a
historically bad year the return you can
hope for over the long term is a few
percent generally speaking
now
it starts to get controversial what is
next
I think you can make the case that
metals are next precious metals gold
silver
Etc
historically historically the return of
gold has been lower than on stocks over
the long term often you're talking about
like four to five percent okay but there
can be volatility there's arguments that
metals have an intrinsic value that
certain other uh assets don't have
precious metals can become extremely
contentious but taking a sort of
objective detached approach you're
probably talking about more risk with
Metals than bond funds and individual
bonds but arguably less than a stock
index fund which would be the next thing
oh hold on I messed that up stock index
fund
stock index funds you're taking on a
little more risk
a stock index fund as I've talked about
before can track the S P 500 or it can
track you know the Russell 2000 or you
could have a total market index in
general this is assigned like seven
percent if you stay in it for the really
long term you're going to earn seven
percent a year you can have years where
you lose 30 percent okay so risk and
volatility are absolutely higher now
this gets tricky
is real estate next
well it depends on your perspective this
is tricky because in addition to being
an investment
you could be talking about real estate
as a primary residence and you're
getting a place to live but in this
context we really want to think more
about it as buying like a Reit a real
estate investment trust or purchasing an
additional home which you might rent out
or make an income property housing
market is known for booms and busts
there is risk from the overall economy
when it comes to real estate there's
interest rate risk when it comes to
mortgages on real estate there are
Regional issues where some parts of the
country do better than others sometimes
you hear people talk about a 10 return
it is way more modest that the reality
is it is way more modest particularly if
you have a mortgage on the property and
what people often don't consider I
recently had a conversation with someone
they said oh my goodness my parents they
bought a house for 120 Grand 30 years
ago they sold it for 1.5 million okay so
it looks like 1.3 million in profit
first of all what did inflation do to
that over that 20 or 30 year period
secondly they had a mortgage mortgage
payments are overwhelmingly interest at
the beginning what is their total of
payments over that period of time what
do they pay on real estate taxes Etc so
where exactly real estate goes is sort
of controversial what helps to mitigate
the risk of real estate is typically
people buy property with the intention
of holding it for a long time which
means
it can recover if the market crashes all
right next in terms of uh level of risk
and volatility
is individual
stocks
and I think I should say you know you
could make the case that real estate
maybe should be below stock index fund
this is not cut and dry it's sort of a
spectrum
um individual stocks much more risky
I believe money you put into individual
stocks you should be prepared to lose
maybe even all of it companies go
bankrupt all the time individual stocks
give you the opportunity to double
triple your money I think uh as some of
you know I used to own Tesla stock I
think my average return on Tesla stock
was sixteen hundred percent but
how many of my investments didn't do
anything or even lost money during that
period of time
investing in companies like Apple and
Google
is going to be safer than many small cap
companies that no one's ever heard of on
average but if you decide to put money
in individual stocks you should expect
to get a much larger return to consider
it a good investment to make up for the
additional risk that you are taking
and then at the top we could have
something like crypto
crypto is super volatile it's new I'm
sure most of you know how risky it is
Bitcoin is the most well established
crypto and it has massive swings in 2020
it was up 300 percent 2021 it went up 60
and 22 it's down 67 percent it would
have to quadruple from its current price
to get to an all-time high there are alt
coins that are even riskier than Bitcoin
this is why I've said before I've only
ever had three percent of my assets in
crypto during those huge upward swings I
would keep selling back down to three
percent to lock in my gains and I still
have only three percent there now and
then maybe like even Beyond this we
could mention gambling
when you look at the expected return on
gambling it's sort of like one of the
riskiest things you can do playing the
lottery betting on sports you could lose
all your money there's the addiction
risk there's also sorts of other things
if you hold a stock or crypto and it
goes down a lot
you still have the shares or the coins
unless they go completely bankrupt and
someday it can recover with gambling the
money is just gone this is a general
framework you can argue with it you can
disagree with it but it's a good initial
framework to think about risk